my name is John Summerhill I have
probably made about 15 knives from start
to finish I am a high school assistant
principal so every day is an adventure
I'm ready for anything that's coming at
me and I look forward to trying to adapt
and beat those odds
my name is Daniel lovano I got into
blade smithing when I went to the
Renaissance Festival and then realized
there were guys that were still doing it
I'm here to have fun but I'm also here
to win
my name is Mike vanoy I'm a full-time
farrier and I'm part-time leadsmith I'm
used to dealing with the unknown because
when I go to a new barn in the morning
you just never know how the horse is
going to react to what you're doing you
just never know what's going to happen
all right I hope that you're ready to
spring into action this is your first
challenge
you are going to engage in the little
spring Big Spring challenge you must
combine at least three small Springs
with a section of the large spring to
forge a Billet from which you will make
a signature blade in your signature
style good luck blade Smiths your 10
minute design window starts
now I'm designing a mix between a camp
knife and a sax
the sacks is very much meant for
chopping and for slicing I started
making blades not long after I started
shoeing horses mainly using old rasps or
files my design is a camp knife slash
chopper with a slightly recurved blade
it'll be a heavy Blade with some heft to
it that'll just hold up well my plan is
to make a large Camp knife it will be
thick it'll be able to handle cutting
through some hard surfaces but at the
same time slice do something then
I know first thing I need to do is cut
off two pieces of my large coil
so Mike's just come away from the pantry
with one of our canisters I'm going to
leave the can on with going through that
pipe chop I want a little bit of soft
Steel on the spine and I think that'll
work out good
I clean the metal up I put white out in
got her in the porch heating it up once
I got about 15 minutes in I'm good to go
with pulling that out now John's taking
a very hot Billet over to the press as
I'm setting the welds I'm feeling pretty
good I don't have anything falling apart
it is doing exactly what it's supposed
to be doing
the only thing that I'm nervous about is
if I can't get the canister off of
material inside
and finally
the Billet falls to the ground and I
have defeated the canister
trophy my abilities forged welded solid
into one solid piece of Steel
now I'm going to draw it out so I can
establish a Tang
and actually Forge a point into the
knife
I've never done canister Damascus before
look at that
the clock is ticking away and I know
it's going to take a while to make this
canister Damascus somebody to think it's
hot enough I can't tell when you think
it's hot enough wait another minute or
two
good advice and now I gotta go Forge
weld it
I start to press it together and it just
starts to fall apart
point I'm kind of panicking please just
shove that lidless coffin back into the
Forge from what I know with canister
Damascus you usually want to take the
canister off anyways so
one last step if Daniel had to put any
kind of flux in in that canoe you know
maybe have a shot of getting that stuff
to stick I'm hoping to salvage something
from it it's here to hoping
they start drawing out the build
it's looking good
then I looked a little closer and I
start to see little tiny cracks now I've
got to make a decision at this point how
I'm going to solve this issue
my first priority here is to fill those
gaps so that the blade is structurally
sound if I Quench and there's no
cracking I know my welds are good and
solid
Michael just punched his wife first
quench blade
files biting into the blade a little bit
so I know it's not completely hardened
the way I'd like it to be I hate to
quench again but I don't quite trust it
punch the second time and I pull it out
it does seem harder than the first time
so I think I'm good
John is just quenched this blade as well
if I pull the blade out of the Quench
and I let it cool off
I'm fairly confident at this point I've
got a pretty hard blade
a can that was falling apart somehow he
managed to get that thing welded into
something that looks somewhat solid with
so much time spent on trying to get a
workable Billet I need to shape my blade
fast
[Music]
I'm playing a dangerous game with cat
and mouse with the clock I need to go
heat treat it
I'm only going to get one shot at this
clinch I have no room for Eric
there he goes Daniel is
I don't have time to file check it I
don't have time to clean it up I still
have to etch it
five four three two one this first round
of competition is over blade Smith's
congratulations you've made it to round
two and now that those blades have been
tempered it's time to turn them into
fully functioning knives by attaching
handles to them good luck your three
hour Starts Now
my first priority is to cut the Tang
down what I need to do is cut off an
inch within the last third of the Tang
because I want there to be a swell so
that the knife won't slip out of your
hands well right now I'm getting a
little frustrated because I can't drill
through my Tang so I'm going to sharpen
the bit and see if that works I was in a
really good spot but this is kind of
putting me behind
oh
I just shortened my handle and then I
got to get over and make a mosaic pen
that I've never done before in my life
John's putting a lot of his weight into
this drill press as soon as you bear
into a Tungsten Carbide bit it just
shatters
I look and see that there's little tiny
hole sticking through the carbide bit
started through the other side so I grab
a chisel and I start tapping on that
carbide bit and luckily it comes out
now I'm back in business
Daniel went down a rabbit hole trying to
make a hidden Tang design this is going
to be a matte dash for Daniel Mann I
wasted a ton of time trying to do this
burn through when I could have just
started with two pieces of wood from the
get-go
moving on to placing the pins in and
before you know it I'm working on the
sides of the scales thinning them out
and putting a good texture in
the more I'm grinding the more I'm
seeing that my handle scale isn't tight
against my Tang the last thing I need is
for one of the handle scales to pop off
during testing
so I'm going to have to fill this in
with some epoxy this time I used a thin
wire that I used out of for my Mosaic
pen to sort of push the epoxy down into
the crack
10 minutes blade Smiths
everything absolutely everything has
taken me much longer than it should have
the biggest concern right now is getting
all the parameters in I'm running out of
time he has a sharp in his blade and his
handle is just incomplete all the way
around
yeah it's glued up 36 grit it man
he's got a pretty aggressive belt but
it's not a new belt no it's the same
belt he's had the entire time yeah the
pressure's on the glue isn't fully set
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one
placement stop what you doing drop your
tools pull your blade out of that
accident
this second round of competition is over
blade space welcome to the strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your age as well as the overall
construction of your knives I'm going to
attempt to crush these copper pipes
Mike you're up you ready I was born
ready
[Music]
thank you
well Mike your Edge held up beautifully
there's no deformation of any kind the
only real issue I had with it is that
the handle is a little round and that
did make it twist in my hand on one of
the strikes I had to double down and
grab a little bit tighter but well done
thank you
John you're up next
do it
John your Edge held up beautifully the
only way I would know that there's
actually ever even hit a copper pipe is
the the smear of copper on the on the
sides it's light it's fast it's fun to
swing nice job thank you
yeah New York how you feeling
discouraged discouraged
my biggest concern here is my handle
staying on the Tang is too small and I
just did not get enough resin on the
inside
there
it's exactly where I thought well Daniel
this hardly qualifies to honestly be a
knife the handle is essentially a block
of wood I mean it it's not really even
glued at this end unfortunately in its
current state it's it's not safe to test
Daniel we commend any Smith that walks
through those doors and puts their
skills to the test in this Forge and
you've proven yourself to be a tenacious
competitor however tenacity wasn't
enough today and I have to ask you to
please leave a forge
I'm really disappointed that I'm not
going to see my knife tested but I
completely understand without a good
handle a blade is just a paperweight I'm
going home got my head held high you
live and learn another day